dans un instant je vous le dis on ira
chez un des chroniqueurs mais il n'y
aura pas que ça il y a il y en a un qui
aime particulièrement
un objet qui lui appartient vraiment il
est fou de cet objet il est fou voilà 2
2 ce qui lui permet de venir tous les
jours à des mythes
c'est bien sûr sa voiture [ __ ]
on est tranquille
j'aurais juste vous montrer quelque
chose c'est une vidéo qu'on a trouvé ça
n'a rien à voir ce qui va se passer ici
les regarde oh [ __ ] c'est qu'est ce
que c'est que ça alors là c'est une
dépanneuse et au est ce que quelqu'un
recoller sa voiture marche bien c'est
moi c'est ça gk keynes marque blanche
comme ça oui il ya une aura oui oui
c'est bon yakhi qui d'autre des temps si
on accuse yake laura alors ça doit que
la voiture des deux quoi qu'est ce qu'il
ya mais les banques soutiennent oui et
vous pareil mais
on peut par voie d'accord mais on l'a vu
aux ongles ou chez noir alors les champs
toujours busquets au fait qu'est ce
qu'il a à la nasa venue parce que j'ai
deux passions
oui les montres et les voitures ah oui
il aurait votre voiture
bah oui fao et la danse anciens ouais
ouais je sais je sais mais ça m'étonne
telle histoire parce qu'aujourd'hui je
suis tombé en panne avec les way
et donc voilà les chais ne marche plus
donc allé chez
je sais monde est allé à chercher aux
achats d'or des grands malheurs
oui désolé mon champ elle a annoncé
l'arrêt c'est peut-être pas celle de
mathieu arrête en chercher une juste la
voiture qu'on est allé chercher à
l'intérieur
roujan nan mais rata un cursus non mais
sérieux c'est une option que j'ai traîné
je serai n'existe pas dans les caisses
perdent le cuir rouge fait l'histoire la
vraie du coup je vous jure que c'est
vrai c'est un cuir à part que j'ai fait
poser shehzad bref vous jure coûté 3
tonnes moi je propose tout de suite 5
sûrs qu'on fasse qu'on fasse qu'on fasse
la séquence du monster truck
écouter avant de voir ces quelques
chroniqueurs on est allé c'est pour ça
que je dis c'est pas mathieu mathieu
vous allez avoir dans un instant des
nouvelles de votre voiture
mathieu bien vu je vais vous poser cinq
questions a remis dans le bain de la
question mais pourquoi il était si vous
allez pouvoir la sauver
j'allais pouvoir la sauver toute façon
elles marchent plus qu'ils nous
emmerdent la batterie et à la batterie
attention c'est des questions c'est des
questions sur touche pas à mon poste
d'accord j'ai posé cinq questions sur ce
qui s'est passé pendant ces trois ans
est ce qu'on peut voir s'il vous plaît
ce qu'on peut avoir une image
faites un plan fait un plan sur l'autre
d'abord aller aller s'y fait un plan
réduite et voilà la messe est restée
sèche mais là-dessus rester là dessus
s'ils veulent d'abord steven à ce que
vous pouvez montrer ce que vous savez
faire un matthieu delormeau simone
voilà alors ça
c'était une voiture qui était à la casse
mathieu je vais tout faire pour que vous
sauviez votre voiture
je vous aime mathieu et bien sûr mais
pas de ceux-là mais elle à la vitre noir
la mienne à la va-vite renoir aussi
comme ça
moi je fais la même chose avec le c'est
en voiture
merci alors mathieu voici la première
question tu te plait je fais une danse
garder ce mec j'ai lu ce gars gagnent
alors mais si vous la sauvez vous faites
une danse ah ben oui si je la sens j'ai
ce que tu veux mais non
mathieu voici la première question le 4
décembre 2013 dans touche pas à mon
poste on se bat plaque a non seulement
arrêter de montrer la voiture de mathieu
arrêtée saoule arrêtez arrêtez d'amour
et pas le fou le bourdon alors par
mathieu mathieu à chaque fois que vous
répondrez mal seewen avancera d'un mètre
si vous faites trois erreurs
il avancera jusqu'à la voiture et steven
est inarrêtable
mathieu aussi la question
le 4 décembre 2013 dans tpm p une vraie
info sur gérard louvin est tombé
laquelle il a fait de la coloc avec
dette dans les années 60 il a une tante
qui s'appelait soeur gérarld où il a été
le premier producteur de t'choupi en
france alors si vous voyez la première
il a fait de la coloc avec dave dans les
années 60 il a une tante qui s'appelait
soeur gérard où il a été le premier
producteur de t'choupi en france dès le
ce1 amis donc je connais mon arrêt
parler c'est la 3 il est déjà monté dans
votre voiture day oui absolument
attention non c'est la 3 donc il a été
le premier producteur de tubes qui en
france
regardez la réponse en images moi
j'avais une tente ma grand tante qui
s'appellent sorj erhard qui était dit le
gérant girarde à gérard jean gérard qui
était si ma soeur non mais comment ça
pas vous manquer mais non non ce vol pas
m'excuser parce que ma soeur est en
pension là bas et quand je dis que j'ai
passé deux mois pendant 6 ans de 12 ans
à 18 ans j'allais de toul
regardez regardez un petit peu de
respect pour ce soir gérard s'il vous
plaît c'est terrible j'allais tous les
quinze jours passé quinze jours dans
l'école dans la robe est simple
les spectateurs du shérif il ya un
scooter à gagner dans un instant on va
vous appeler l'inde en 3 48 heures pour
gueuler bastia bons fous d'avoir un
scooter a dit mais bon voilà bien lui me
dit trois arrêtés alors je le dis s'il
vous plaît les chéris c'était bien sûr
surgira dont vous avez perdu
vous nous avez vous appellera dans un
instant hashtag cadeau pour gagner ce
magnifique scooter que vous pouvez voir
voilà qui est laquée sur le plateau
attention deuxième question quel
footballeur a provoqué un fou rire sur
ce plateau le 7 février 2013 mathieu a
doublé l'avancé de m stephen âmes est
mon bébé
saft
marc occupa
c'est bon c'est bon et recul est bon et
rck
quatre footballeurs a provoqué un fou
rire sur ce plateau le 7 février 2013
arrêter de montrer sa voiture ça nous
déprime michel ça pue nicolas sachy ou
pierre ses couilles
alors match aller je serai plus là vous
m'agacer alors attendez pas pu aller de
la 2 donc nicolas sachy basse et salades
horaires non alors ça pue michel sapin
dans la voiture
est-ce que ça chie existe oui ça qui
n'en sache y voyait alors arrigo sacchi
c'est un entraîneur mais là ça chie
exister il existe c est le gardien de
but de l'équipe de sedan et zambie un
jour un jour l'équipe a titré s'agit
dans les vestiges plus qu'aux
téléspectateurs c'est que j'ai fait tout
ce quiz juste pour cette date
mathieu en tout cas pour vous ça chie
passe à puce
steven avant internet mon bébé ça donne
des matchs notre dame
seulement on
oui là
alors attention les full options et
légendes sport en plus il reste encore
trois questions n'aient plus droit à
l'erreur au bout sans déconner naturel
je vous posais une question la voici
mathieu je sais que vous êtes un grand
littéraire pouvez vous me dire quel a
été le tout premier livre lu dans voyage
au bout de la nuit sur des 8 à 6 voilà
c'est mort la poste auch ashton joue des
deux coups nature géodonnées trois
propositions
oui oui oui et la gomme magique non
le grand meaulnes un peut-être de
gustave flaubert ce grand bol et
jacinthe fourni on est alain fourny
exactement qui avait entraîné le paris
saint germain ou bien le horla de guy de
maupassant et de graines guy de
maupassant
mathieu là je crois savoir si vous
répondez bien c'est fini
non mais reste encore deux questions
ça passe par contre bresso tu peux
second rôle de la voiture le grand bol
matthieu delormeau
si ça n'est pas le grand meaulnes
malheureusement steven va avancer si
c'est le grand bol on oublie tout pour
le moment c'est vous matthieu delormeau
matthieu delormeau
vous avez deux passions dans la vie le
kung fu et votre voiture
malheureusement vous avez arrêté deux
fois l'âge de 6 ans mathieu pour le
moment il ya un monster truck à mons au
fait qu'ils ne pensent qu'à une chose
c'est cracher votre voiture que vous
aimez je vous ai posé une question juste
avant la pause mathieu cette question
c'est est est ce que vous pouvez me dire
quel a été le tout premier livre lu dans
voyage au bout de la nuit sur des huit
mâts et d'y voir de grands mots le
groupe legrand maul alain fourny oui
vous l'avez lu ce livre
oui parler quoi on tend goûter mathieu
je sais que vous n'êtes pas en état de
me résumer suivre offrait une fiche de
lecture pour lundi
le premier livre qui a été lu dans
voyage au bout de la nuit
c'est le horla
voilà la donne non mais tu te plais
festival il va avancer mon va lui
laisser une dernière chance
on va lui laisser bien des rechanges
quoi ça sera la dernière chance de
mathieu d'accord avant c'est steven
avancée mais voilà la base
ça
agent ou
la dernière question j'aimerais qu'on
appelle une personne qui s'inscrit sur
twitter et qui va repartir avec un
scooter
allez on appelle tout de suite en direct
avant bien sûr de poser la dernière
question à mathieu c'est parti on
appelle je rappelle que on a plus de
facilité à un monster truck ici qu'à
faire un numéro de téléphone
les touche pas à mon poste des mutas
paradoxe et moi alors la sonnerie et
fortin alors qu'il est à l'appareil
oui walid quand ça va c'est cyril
hanouna et en direct mots acides
elle te plaît l'émission ah bah oui
c'est acquis wahid
est ce que tu veux dire un petit mot à
matthieu delormeau
franchement il est vrai merde
ah non
oui tu nous as tu t'appelles où tu es où
tu habites wade à badens excuse moi
qu'est ce que tu fais tu veux manger un
robot alors je te regarder merci oui tu
veux nous regardent avec toute la
famille chez moi avec ma copine
wahou ballet beau gosse
quel âge wahid ils arrêteront ils
abattent en abattant rien est impossible
attendent et invincible oui tu fais quoi
dans la vie me wade en fac de sport
j'adore la fa qui adore le sport est
bien
wahid je vais t'expliquer la règle du
jeu je vais poser une dernière médiation
du peu éteint la télé enfin à mettre
moins fort au wild t'inquiète pas wahid
je vais t'expliquer la règle du jeu si
matthieu delormeau
sauf sa voiture c'est matthieu delormeau
sauf sa voiture excusez moi il ya des
mecs savall a écrit là derrière la légal
non mais oh hey tu veux pas fermer ta
gueule mais le gars est en train de
raconter sa vie il est derrière les
corps et ouais mais tu sais puis le
doigt on n'a même pas fait constat le
gars est partie à des moments alors oui
mon chéri si si matthieu delormeau
répond bien on écrase a pas sa voiture
mais tu ne repartira malheureusement pas
et que ce doute
dans les règles ont été validés par lui
si on peut pas lui sont pas les changer
ça a été validée là si je m'entends là
pas besoin d'un perroquet wade c'est
matthieu delormeau se trompe et qu'il
perd sa voiture wahid tu auras scooter
et tu pourras venir chercher matthieu
delormeau d'accord il n'y en ait pas
il lui a cherché quelqu'un de chez soi
attention voici la dernière
la dernière question
je crois que tu as reçu un mail oui
attention aussi la question est ce qu'on
peut mettre un peu de côté la seo plaît
merci en régie prenait des trous des
initiatives ou sera pas toujours là
robben vous serez tout seul attention
moi c'est la dernière question est là je
serai plus une dernière chance
je le dit matthew goss qui est pour que
mathieu répondent bien qu'ils sont sa
voiture allumé tout plateau je veux
savoir julien courbet il a le droit à
l'erreur ça sera bien une petite erreur
parce que ça relancera la soirée bref
j'aimerais bien qu'il garde sa voiture
mais pour voiliers de quand même le gym
moi je suis pour qu'on détruit sa
bagnole
aujourd'hui la voiture
non mais vous savez l humour de
situation vous le cuir vous c'est une
faute de goût donc on peut écraser les
détours découvre un peu les transports
en commun je te jure c'est bien aussi
on dira toujours soigné le
téléspectateur donc je lui donne un
conseil pendant la pub gilles mas matin
un peu julien courbet moi je me qui
sauve sa voiture dommage elle est
toujours très premier temps mais c'est
bon tu sais moi j'aime à dire un show
pour la gageure les bassins j'ai pas la
peine j'ai pas besoin qui me ramène
celui ci tu sais j'ai ma vie mes
transports en commun j'ai mon ticket de
métro c'est laura maintenant l'essentiel
c'est quoi il est un cadeau pardonne-moi
par tata plein d'oseille qui va tracer
une voiture aux heures et est la tienne
moi je suppose walid et surtout ça fera
une très belle séquence camille cas mais
j'aime le jeu jallet serait couverte un
don simplement si connaissez mieux
depuis qu'il aurait sauvé sa tête
attends vos questions matthieu delormeau
la voici la question c'est quel est le
surnom donné par olivier minne au père
fouras et et la voilà maintenant mais
s'il vous plaît c'est important ah oui
vous avez deux secondes près il n'ya pas
trop position non mais non non
imposition alors trois secondes
mais ce qui est terrible c'est dans une
autre émission de télé j'ai apprécié
pour une vanne mais vous êtes tellement
tard et tellement je fous là le père fou
mais comment vais je le devine le père
fouras et n'importe quoi un truc logique
à toute logique de père fois
rip chauffer recul le père fois le lait
le père un homme né de père nick a le
permis car le public à regarder la
réponse vous êtes une vraie famille mien
c'est une vraie famille fort boyard vous
connais vous nous aviez dit que vous
aviez même un petit surnom pour le père
fouras la four est j'appelle four est
oui c'est vrai j'ai comme ça il y en a
plein d'autres qui l'appelle foire est
aussi plus que temps c'est bon ça c'est
même âge et s'est propagé
c'est
mauvaise nouvelle on va commencer par la
bonne nouvelle
walid tu gagnes le scooter
à
ensuite il est ce que tu es content
moshe harel est ce que tu as un mot à
dire à mathieu de la mort avant de
partir ce que c'est merci s'arrête walid
franchement toutes mes condoléances à
matthieu delormeau
c'est gagné pour cloyes aller ça c'était
la bonne nouvelle la mauvaise nouvelle
mathieu j'ai des règles j'ai les
huissiers qui sont là qu'est le csa qui
me regarde je peux pas annoncer quelque
chose n'est pas le faire derrière
oui non
stephen
alors attendez voilà
je sais rien c'est vrai c'est rien
c'est bon
c'est beau c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
simone calme-toi mathieu au vrai c'est
bon c'est bon merci jean mathieu mathieu
c'était votre voiture
non mais c'est vrai a bien sûr quitter
sa voiture et un deux jours oui c'est
votre voiture mathieu vous inquiétez pas
on va lancer un appel ensuite à la même
si j'ai même pour cette voiture j'ai le
coeur qui bat même si mathieu on a
quelque chose à vous montrer c'était
votre voiture bien sûr et votre voiture
c'est terminé important de me tuer bien
sûr que c'est votre voiture mathieu mais
mathieu c'est pas une vie on n'est pas
des monstres quand même regarder la
transformation de votre voiture
et
avec les profs une voiture à la casse
une voiture qui était morte et on l'a
reproduit à la même panne moteur cette
voiture c'est elle est à l'identique de
votre voiture donc en fait c'est juste
de la tôle
voilà mon match
pour moi c'est impossible sun vannes
c'est parce que franchement le cuir
rouge comme savent qu'elles seront
aucune vous être que la nièvre est basse
et un mandat on l'a reproduite vous dis
à l'identique merci steve merci
bien sûr on n'a pas massacré vie
l'ablation de leurs monnaies une autre
voiture suit une voiture voilà c'est
juste de la tôle
elle était déjà morte la voiture voilà
mon mathieu de leurs beaux
applaudissements produits